[Musik]
schweizer konzerne sollen auch im
ausland menschenrechte und
umweltstandards einhalten
dies verlangt die sogenannte konzern
verantwortungs initiative
das klingt selbstverständlich gestritten
wird aber über den weg zu diesem ziel
für die initiative machen sich auch
kirchliche hilfswerke und kirchenleute
stark ist das zulässig und ist die
initiative der richtige weg gegen
kinderarbeit menschenrechtsverletzungen
und umweltverschmutzung darüber
debattieren jetzt im studio bernd nie
ließ er ist sozial und
politikwissenschaftler und er ist
geschäftsführer des fasten opfers des
hilfswerks der katholikinnen und
katholiken in der schweiz er ist für die
initiative und markus huppenbauer er ist
theologe und ethiker und leitet das
zentrum für religion wirtschaft und
politik in zürich das institut ist
getragen von mehreren schweizer
universitäten er ist gegen die
initiative daher open bauer wenn sie
jetzt theologinnen theologen kirchliche
hilfswerke gläubige für diese initiative
einsetzen können sie dieses engagement
nachvollziehen ja unbedingt konferenz
einzelne christen menschen sind die das
sind tun
es geht ja um menschenrechte geht es um
wichtige moralische gemüter die jetzt zu
verteidigen geld und das sich hier
kirchen christenmenschen engagieren
dafür habe ich vollstes verständnis
mehr noch ich finde es auch gut dass sie
das tun aber sie als ethiker sind jetzt
dagegen das erstaunt doch erst ja ich
bin gegen die initiative aber nicht
dagegen dass wir menschenrechte
respektieren dass wir alles tun um
menschenrechte zu schützen auch im
wirtschaftlichen kontext wo ich ein
problem habe ich es mit sozusagen mit
der mit der art und weise wie das die
initiative erklären wenn sie gehören ja
mit dem fasten opfer sozusagen zu den
trägern zur trägerschaft der initiative
was motiviert sie denn diese initiative
zu unterstützen
wir sind überwunden hat organisationen
viele aus der kirche also kirchlichen
raum reformierte katholiken
die da zusammengekommen sind aufgrund
der erfahrungen die wir machen in afrika
asien lateinamerika
die welt hat sich verändert die
unternehmen operieren überall auf der
welt haben geschäftsbeziehungen wir
konsumenten konsumieren obst gemüse aus
aller welt mein handy kommt aus teilen
zusammen aus aller welt
und dort wo wir arbeiten als
hilfsorganisationen treffen wir immer
mehr die unternehmen an und diese
produktionsstätten und sehen auch
auswirkungen davon und deswegen haben
wir uns zusammengeschlossen um eine
initiative zu starten die dafür sorgt
dass bestimmte menschenrechts und
umweltstandards bei diesen investitionen
dort vor ort auch eingehalten werden
weit entfernt von der schweiz aber sehr
nah an den armen bevölkerungsgruppen mit
denen wir arbeiten eben das klingt doch
nachvollziehbar also ich würde fast
sagen ist es nicht so wenn jetzt jemand
gegen die initiative ist verrät zb als
gläubiger oder gläubigen nicht
eigentlich dann ein herzstück die
solidarität zum beispiel des glaubens
ich hätte kein verständnis dafür wenn
gläubige oder kirchen menschen sitzen
menschen sich gegen das moralische
anliegen wenden und das ist glaube ich
unbestritten da haben wir denke ich auf
den konsens unternehmen müssen in ihren
wirtschaftlichen aktivitäten
menschenrechte einhalten
da gibt es keine diskussion wir müssen
vielleicht diskutieren was sind
eigentlich menschenrechte es gibt sehr
unterschiedliche menschenrechte
das ist das eine aber noch einmal hat
die frage ist eigentlich wirklich wie
wollen wir dafür sorgen dass global an
diesem von der schweiz ihr weiter
entfernten orten menschenrechte
eingehalten
und da war wenn sie den weg es geht um
wieder in betrieb um das instrument mit
dem genauer schauen wir uns noch angehen
aber wohl sagen sie wo ist da der
eigentliche punkt also für mich ist kein
problem bestimmte sorgfaltspflichten
berichterstattungspflicht wie sie auch
vorgesehen sind für mich ist der
knackpunkt dieser diese haftungs
möglichkeit diese klagemöglichkeit als
der geschädigte und es gibt geschädigte
da müssen wir gar nicht darüber
diskutieren
rechts und in zukunft die möglichkeit
wenn die initiative angenommen wird vor
einem schweizer gericht zu klagen
und das hat nicht mal so geländer so
weit weg passieren und es wird dann hier
verhandelt wenn er warum diese
verrechtlichung die vorgesehen ist wie
gesagt wir kommen dazu
das ist für sie ein der haupt- oder ein
problematischer schauen wir uns mal ein
beispiel an vor wenigen wochen anfang
mai und wegen der generalversammlung und
die zement firma volz im eine
schweizerisch französische firma in den
medien da hieß es zement riese steht
wegen kinderarbeit am pranger und läufer
stolz sie müht sich in afrika und im
nahen osten ab was war jetzt genau der
vorwurf sie waren ja mit dabei bei der
generalversammlung also die leute von
ihnen auch von den hilfswerken die das
da eingebracht haben ja also die konzern
verantwortungs initiative möchte ja die
sorgfaltspflicht von der sie gesprochen
haben verbindlich machen und dazu gehört
dass sich maßnahmen ergreife die
präventiv wirken daß ich habe auch wenn
was schief gegangen ist die menschen
entschädige zum beispiel genau da ist
was schief gegangen mit kinderarbeit und
hier ist massiv was schiefgegangen hier
war es möglich dass bei einem
tochterunternehmen über zehn jahre
kinder dort bei der zementproduktion bei
der rohstoffausbeutung tätig waren und
das unternehmen hat das geduldet hat es
nichts gemacht als wir dann die
öffentlichkeit gegangen sind fasst laut
ford zusammen auch mit dem schwester
hilfswerk brot für alle von der
reformierten kirche haben wir hat das
unternehmen sofort reagiert hat die
kinder nach hause geschickt aber sie
sind jahrelang nichts der schule
gegangen sie haben auch gesundheitliche
schäden und wir kommen einfach nicht an
den punkt der der auch der
wiedergutmachung und das beobachten wir
überall auf der welt wo was passiert
dass die menschen danach allein gelassen
werden das heißt sie haben kontakt mit
den betroffenen vor ort er
wir sind durch als fasten opfer wir sind
zum beispiel in 14 ländern und wir
arbeiten ja sehr eng auch mit anderen
hilft zusammen organisation zusammen
tauschen uns aus
informationen erfahrungen und dadurch
haben wir sehr gutes wissen ein sehr
großes wissen wir haben sehr viele
studien veröffentlicht und haben immer
wieder den unternehmen diese studien
vorgelegt und haben gehofft zunächst
dass sie darauf reagieren würden dass
sich wirklich etwas ändern würde
aber so eine endlose geschichte der
studien die wir machen müssten genau ich
trage aber auch noch das love rocks ihm
eine eigene studie in
auftrag gegeben hat und danach eben
keine hinweise dass bei hima sind also
dieser firma zu liefer oder in der
zulieferkette je kinderarbeit gegeben
habe also es bestreiten sie und eine
sprecherin sagt jetzt eben anlässlich
der generalversammlung wir sind dabei
mit dem bau von sanitäranlagen für
kinder in der mongolei ist cool zu
starten
also da geht offenbar etwas geht mir
jetzt auch nicht darum hier zu
entscheiden oder zu urteilen was sagen
sie zu solchen beispiel die sind
erschütternd muss man sagen sowas geht
es nicht wobei gerade bei kinderarbeit
ist natürlich die sache auch haben wir
waren viele familien in solchen gegenden
die wenig ökonomische möglichkeiten
bieten sind darauf angewiesen dass alle
familienmitglieder mitarbeiten also
insofern sicht auch eine gewisse
spannung habe ich finde das eigentlich
sehr gut dass hilfswerke beispielsweise
sehr nahm den menschen sind und auch die
bedürfnisse sehen dieser menschen und
für diese menschen einstehen sind da
haben sie eine sehr wichtige funktion in
meinen augen aber man sieht schon das
problem mit dem was sie gezeigt haben es
gibt da nicht studie es gibt da
erfahrung und es gibt eine andere studie
und hier der wirtschaft sagt das sind
einzelne schwarze schafe aber ich würde
das eigentlich auch so sehen dass weg
auf dem flop aber über das jahr gesehen
gibt es vermutlich mehrere millionen
geschäftliche transaktionen von
schweizer unternehmen mit ländern über
die wir hier reden und ich gehe davon
aus dass der größte teil dieser
geschäftlichen transaktionen moralisch
in ordnung ist und insofern würde ich
tatsächlich sagen es gibt probleme kann
man nicht agieren
aber es sind sehr wenige probleme aber
nachfrage wenn wir jetzt von
menschenrechten regen die es dann dort
werden sie ein schweiz gelten warum
sollten die nicht gelten die sollen
selbstverständlich auch da gelten das
wäre ja hier dann da rein das ist genau
wobei ja schon diskutiert wird wer hat
eigentlich diesen schaden verursacht und
das ist eben das was sie dann vor
gericht klären müssen
und dann werden wir genau solche
situationen haben streitparteien ewig
lange prozesse das wird den geschädigten
nicht wirklich helfen also das problem
ist eben kein einzelfall
die vereinten nationen alle nationen der
erde haben sich mit diesem problem
befasst
dass die menschenrechte die allgemeine
erklärung der menschenrechte die
wichtigen menschenrechts packte dass es
da eine lücke gibt nämlich dass staaten
verantwortlich sind dass wir inzwischen
auch einzelpersonen teilweise diktatoren
ein zugriff bekommen nach
internationalem recht aber dass die
unternehmen sich da in einem freien raum
bewegen können
der der rechtlich keine konsequenzen hat
und das ist ein beschluss der vereinten
nationen
den hat die schweiz mitgetragen 2011 und
wir möchten dass dieser weltweite
beschluss in der schweiz jetzt in das
gesetz übernommen wird in die verfassung
übernommen wird
und das ist eigentlich unsere unser
unser vorschlag das ist die konzern
verantwortungs initiative im kern und im
detail stellt sich das dann eben so da
das unternehmen wirklich eine
sorgfaltspflicht haben und das will auch
die uno schauen uns kann ja was soll
sich da konkret ändern würde wir haben
bisher den artikel 101 der
bundesverfassung da steht der bhc und
wahrt die interessen der schweizerischen
wirtschaft im ausland neu würde hier
artikel 101 ausstehen
der bund trifft massnahmen zur stärkung
der respektierung der menschenrechte und
der umwelt durch die wirtschaft das
klingt nun doch schon ganz anders im
erreicht würde das wird ja dann im
initiativtext ausgeführt mit einer
sogenannten sorgfalts prüfungspflicht
was heißt das konkret
das heißt dass ein unternehmen alles tun
muss um probleme zu erkennen wenn ich
einen vertrag eingehen
mit einem zulieferer oder wenn ich eine
tochterfirma gründe in asien afrika
lateinamerika in einem anderen land habe
ich eine verantwortung dass ich der
regeln aufstelle dass ich gucke ob es da
schutzstandards gibt es für die
näherinnen in der textilfabrik oder wenn
ich eine bergbau mine eröffne muss ich
gucken ist die nicht in einem bild
naturreservat bevor ich da loslege vor
ich wirklich loslegen ist sie mitten
diese mine ist die mitten im regenwald
wird dafür massiv regenwald abgeholzt es
gibt voraussetzungen die wir da
einfordern und firmen die daten müssten
berichte erstellen und das auch jetzt
prüfen genau das ist eigentlich genau
der punkt den sie gerade schon mal
angesprochen hatten die studie zb die
dann lafarge holzem vorgelegt oder eben
nicht vorgelegt hat ist dies nicht
öffentlich wir haben keinen zugang zu
die
informationen und die konzern
verantwortungs initiative hätte als teil
der sorgfaltspflicht auch die
transparenz das heißt wir würden dann
endlich mal die karten auf dem tisch
haben also eine sorgsame prüfung das
macht ja sehen da haben sie mich absolut
niveau das ich teile die meinung da gehe
ich auch weiter also einige kreise in
der wirtschaftlich halte diese sorgfalt
prüfungspflicht ich halte die
berichterstattungspflicht für absolut
relevant
ich kann diesen fall nicht ich finde es
bedauerlich dass wir keinen zugriff
haben auf diese studie
das müssten wir um wirklich entscheiden
zu können was wir sind immer wieder
beispielsweise holdings die sagen aber
die schweizer firmen die benehmen sich
im ausland schauen ja diese unter diesen
richtlinien also da gibt es gar keine
ich vermute da haben wir tatsächlich
auch ein unterschied denn schon in der
beschreibung der situation
ich habe tatsächlich den eindruck es
seien im wesentlichen schwarze schafe
seien einzelfälle wo wir ein problem
haben aber das im schnitt jedenfalls den
einigen branchen nicht hin da würde ich
ihm vermutlich auch zu recht geben dass
wir recht gut unterwegs sind auf alles
was jetzt sozusagen angewandt haben denn
die schwarzen schafe
ich denke nach rohstoffbereich ist nach
wie vor ein problem wobei auch da sehe
ich bei einigen pferden bewegung wenn
sie zum beispiel im lebensmittelbereich
konsum generell textilien da habe ich
den eindruck da sind wir an einem
wirklich anderen ort aussagen wir vor 20
jahren es also ich würde auch sagen je
näher wie beim kunden sind mit einem
produkt umso mehr schaut auch die
öffentlichkeit so umso mehr wird druck
auf die unternehmen ausgeübt hatte da
können unternehmen heute gingen nicht
mehr machen die vor 20 jahren problemlos
möglich waren
also insofern glaube ich wirklich haben
viele grosse schweizer unternehmen
einiges gelernt also bei der vorprüfung
der pflicht da höre ich gewisse
einigkeit heraus bei der haftung wird
daher schwieriger wo liegt da eigentlich
das problem wir haben ja kurz
angesprochen also nächtlich auch dann
ein gladbacher schmerz wir sind ja beide
keine juristen und es ist juristen
futter und deswegen würde ich primär
sagen die juristen streiten sich darüber
ob das wirklich ein effizientes
instrument sein werde und man wirklich
den es zu gut
helfen werden können ich weiß es
letztlich nicht ich vermute dass es zu
einer verrechtlichung insofern führen
wird dass nicht mehr leute die sich für
menschenrechte und so weiter
interessieren den firmen
sorgfaltspflichten ausarbeiten sondern
es werden die juristen sein um vor dem
hintergrund einer klage möglichkeit
während die versuchen alles wasserdicht
zu machen
es wird an flexibilität veränderten
konkreten situation ist jetzt nicht mehr
um bedürfnisse gehens werden nur noch
darum gehen dass die unternehmen
rechtlich möglichst abgesichert sind
oder sich dann zurückziehen und damit
ist meines erachtens niemanden gedient
also das problem hat verschiedene ebenen
das eine ist das thema tut sich schon
was und da muss ich sagen ja aber das
liegt vor allen dingen an den
konsumentinnen und konsumenten die auch
inzwischen etwas druck machen aber die
auch sehr hilflos dastehen sie wissen
oft nicht was in ihrem produkt das
wissen sie auch in ihrem handy der blut
rann klebt oder nicht das ist sie nicht
darüber wird da schon debattiert und da
gibt der nativen aber ja wir kennen die
alternative sehr begrenzt ich höre aus
die initiative will auch druck machen
aber jetzt in dem punkt verraten wer zu
der ferrari um genau diese
verrechtlichung des zentralen weil wir
ja nicht jetzt plötzlich auf dieser welt
gelandet sind heute und alles neu
beginnt sondern wir beobachten seit
jahrzehnten
diese massiven problemen die massive
umweltzerstörung wir haben ja zum
beispiel auch fragen bis hin zu
klimawandel die zerstörung des
regenwaldes das hängt ja alles damit
zusammen dass wir keine regeln
aufgestellt haben dass man ständig über
rot fahren kann ohne dass was passiert
und jetzt braucht es diese haftungs
dimension in dem sinne dass es geht hier
um eine haftung bezüglich
sorgfaltspflicht das heißt das
unternehmen wenn ein unternehmen
wirklich alles getan hat ein unternehmen
wirklich präventiv vorgegangen ist wird
ein schweizer gericht antworten das
unternehmen hat gut gewirtschaftet es
gibt gar kein problem wenn also die
unternehmen gut sind und schon guten job
machen wird es nie zu einem verfahren
kommen die verfahren die
haftungsklauseln ist wirklich gemeint
für de facto die schwarzen schafe die
weiterhin über die rote ampel fahren und
einfach nicht mehr
also nicht dass wir in dieser seien
jetzt alle details dieses initiativtext
verhandeln wollten aber wenn wir bei dem
punkt sind strittig ist doch dass für
die ganze zulieferer kette jetzt im
initiativtext für alle beteiligten dass
diese rechtliche klausel vorgesehen ist
wenn ich es richtig verstanden einem
eben nicht also die die sorgfaltspflicht
soll für alle gelten auch die zulieferer
die haftungs seite ist aber nur dann
tritt nur dann in kraft ein gericht kann
nur ein unternehmen verurteilen wenn es
das unternehmen kontrolliert wenn es
also eine tochter ist oder es ist ein
zulieferer der quasi 100 prozent
abhängig ist von dem schweizer
unternehmen also ein de facto kontrolle
besteht und das ist oft auch ein
missverständnis bzw die ökonomie swiss
versucht die ganze zeit politikern das
zu erzählen es stimmt aber nicht und der
bundesrat hat in seiner stellungnahme
dass explizit festgehalten dass kleine
und mittelständische unternehmen der
schweiz sind weitgehend ausgeschlossen
und dass diese abgrenzung die ich gerade
beschrieben habe es bestätigt und das
interessanteste aber andere der
bundesrat hat die initiative abgelehnt
er hat das ist ein witz der bundesrat
hat gesagt ja schweizer unternehmen
verletzen die menschenrechte und das was
ich gerade gesagt habe wird auch
bestätigt und kommt am ende völlig
überraschend zu dem schluss dass die
initiative aber nicht geeignet seien
und da muss man sagen das ist
lobbyarbeit der wirtschaft die hat gut
funktioniert aber das ist nicht das
sachverstand passiert meint gleichwohl
heißt zum beispiel der umfang dieser
sorgfalts prüfung nicht abhängig von den
risiken den bereichen menschenrechte und
umwelt und auch welche firmen jetzt
genau und so also ich denke da gibt es
auch einen gewissen
interpretationsspielraum aber die
nächsten jahr so hinein ins detail gehen
mich interessiert einfach noch die frage
warum eigentlich jetzt schweizer firmen
so sehr in die pflicht genommen werden
sollen zum beispiel denkt an ein land
wie die demokratische republik kongo wo
eigentlich der staat abwesend ist bei
den menschen sich nicht können wird
warum sollen jetzt eigentlich die firmen
da schulen wohnungen sich um die
menschenrechte kümmern
die schweiz ist in ein besonderes land
hier haben sich sehr viele der großen
konzerne die in der ganzen welt
operieren haben sich hier niedergelassen
oder sind hier in der schweiz gewachsen
zu globalen playern und das ist eine
realität
auch in anderen ländern usa
großbritannien frankreich gibt es große
unternehmen und dort gibt es auch schon
gesetzgebungsverfahren die ähnlich der
konzern verantwortung sind das heißt es
gibt einen internationalen rechts trend
und die schweiz wäre jetzt eigentlich
wirklich in einer führungsposition mit
der konzern verantwortung sie würde ein
stück weit mit ein paar anderen ländern
vorangehen und nicht später irgendwann
eigentlich machen müssen was die anderen
dann entwickelt haben was die anderen
vorschreiben die schweizer eine
vorreiterrolle und wir würden unser
verantwortung in der welt gerecht werden
da hier eigentlich zum beispiel öl wird
überwiegend über die schweiz gehandelte
rohstoffe überwiegend über schweiz es
geht alles über den schweizer markt und
das muss man einfach anerkennen den
eindruck sie haben die frage von herrn
bischof berger nicht genau aufgenommen
sie fragen nach kongo sie fragen nach
den staaten innerhalb der schweizer
unternehmen operieren und das geht
tatsächlich so ein bisschen verloren in
der ganzen diskussion dass diese
geistigen prinzips die sie angesprochen
haben von 2011 die machen eine schöne
teilung bezüglich der verantwortung
bezüglich menschenrechten staaten haben
die farben menschenrechte zu schützen
unternehmen haben die verantwortung in
ihrem geschäftlichen aktivitäten
menschenrechte zu respektieren das heißt
wir müssen selbstverständlich auch die
die die die pflichten der schuldig und
gerade an etwas im haus die das wort
entschuldigung ist man sie unterscheiden
die aufgaben geben die staaten haben und
die aufnahmen die die fährt genau und da
gibt es tatsächlich ein problem bei
diesen staaten die die strukturen sind
zu wenig ausgebaut um eben dann auch
durchzusetzen dass menschenrechte
eingehalten werden wo ich ihnen völlig
recht habe ist natürlich
selbstverständlich müssen gerade in
solchen situationen haben unternehmen
die pflicht dafür zu sorgen dass
menschenrechte eingehalten werden ich
glaube übrigens das haben sie ein
bisschen zu einfach schildert ja wir
sind als konsumenten den
denn unternehmen auch völlig
ausgeliefert das glaube ich eigentlich
gar nicht wenn man zurückschaut auf die
letzten 10 20 jahren haben konsumenten
angels evans gerade ihre enorm viel
macht ausüben können und eben mit dazu
beigetragen von mir aus als kleiner
david dass dieser große goliath
wirtschaft tatsächlich in die richtige
richtung geht insgesamt obwohl es noch
viel zu tun gibt
also wir dürfen die augen nicht vor der
realität verschließen
meine aufgabe bei fast ein opfer ist es
auch mit mit zivilorganisationen in der
ganzen welt zusammenzuarbeiten und ich
persönlich sehe vor ort
menschenrechtsverletzung massive
umweltzerstörung furchtbare situationen
die sind da und da müssen wir reagieren
das können wir nicht auf morgen
verschieben und sagen ach sie haben ihre
familie verloren
die wurde durch einen giftigen fluss dem
glencore verseucht hat haben sie ja und
wie keine ethische aufgabe versteht und
es ist nicht nur den leuten helfen
sondern die situation vor ort wird
analysiert und deren namen in sachen
dass er ihn sogar in gestalt von fasten
opfer wir sollen nicht nur helfen hohe
armut ist wir sollen auch fragen warum
die leute an sinn und es gibt regionen
auf der welt wo menschen sehr arm sind
und sehr krank sind und ich habe diese
familien auch besucht in solidarität in
der nähe von bergbau minen die sehr
leiden und keiner hilft ihnen ist es gab
letztens einen dammbruch 19 menschen tot
60.000 menschen haben ihr zuhause
verloren
nicht eine familie ist komplett hat
kompensation hilfe bekommen und das
dürfen wir einfach nicht weiter
tolerieren und deswegen haben wir es
hier auch mit einer realität zu tun die
wir nicht auf morgen verschieben dürfen
zwar sind da sind wir uns einig glaube
ich denke da muss was getan werden noch
einmal ich glaube das instrument das sie
im zarten vorlegen eignet sich dazu
nicht aber die schweiz hat auch schon
ganz viel gemacht schauen wir den
bereich sextourismus an ein schweizer
der kinder in thailand missbraucht wurde
auf den philippinen kann vor einem
schweizer gericht verurteilt werden ein
deutscher autoraser der hier mit 200
durch das land reist wird vor einem
deutschen gericht verurteilt das ist
rechts standard warum nicht für
unternehmen war und ich weiß nicht ob
beispiele morgen mal hinten aber jetzt
kommt ein indirekter gegenvorschlag in
der situation im
moment konnte in die diskussion dieser
indirekte gegenvorschlag zur initiative
greift sage ich mal die wesentlichen
anliegen auch auf diese sorgfaltspflicht
zb ist drin
es gibt ja unterschiedliche scheitern
auch die haftungen screen gedacht ihm 60
und 80 prozent der anliegen der
initiative wären eingelesen wenn es in
etwa den text dann gibt werden sie den
übernehmen die initiative zurückziehen
der gegenvorschlag wie er jetzt vorliegt
da haben wir ganz klar das signal
gegeben dass wir zurückziehen würden
das würde nicht zur abstimmung kommen
hier um zu präzisieren dann würde es auf
gesetzesebene geregelt
es wird auf gesetzesebene geräte in der
aktienrechtsreform in eliminiert
wahrscheinlich und wir hätten einen viel
schnelleren politischen prozess das ist
auch für die betroffenen wichtig für die
für die armen bevölkerungsgruppen die
jetzt leiden
das würde viel alles viel schneller
gehen dafür brauchen wir aber die
unterstützung in parlament und ich denke
die politiker sind inzwischen sehr
sensibel für das thema aber sie stehen
jetzt vor einer sehr wichtigen
entscheidung in wenigen wochen im
nationalrat ob sie noch gegen noch noch
änderungsvorschläge zu lassen
und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen dass
dann unsere große koalition musste sich
dann noch mal zurückziehen und genau
klären ob wir dann wirklich zurückziehen
also weitere aufweichungen halte ich die
problematik
ok also da sind wir jetzt habe ich gar
nicht so unterschiedlich sind zwar auch
nicht hell begeistert von diesem
indirekten gegenvorschlag aber es würde
damit es gibt politischen spielraum sag
ich mal
und bisher hatten wir einfach procontra
initiative das ist eine möglichkeit also
es wird auch so ein bisschen eingegrenzt
vom welchen schäden reden wir nicht
einfach von menschenrechtsverletzungen
das ist wirklich sehr viel sagen es geht
um schäden am leib leben und eigentum
also wirklich ganz speziellen dinge und
ich glaube sind auch nur unternehmen
einer bestimmten größe beispielsweise
macht auch sein dass noch umstritten
genauso geschrieben aber sowohl auf der
suche sein unternehmen einschränken
die einmal geschätzt dass es nach
unserem vorschlag um etwa 1500 machen
eben geht
und es gibt politiker die versuchen das
auch um die 1000 runter zu schrauben
überall sind wir etwas besorgt dass man
da wenn
einige die in diesen sensiblen bereichen
arbeiten vielleicht herausfinden üben
zwar ihre fallschirme wieder das ausland
frankreich erwähnt
unter diesen neuen französischen regeln
farben meines wissens etwa 150 der
größten französischen konzerne sind sehr
viel weniger als in der schweiz
ich glaube wenn dieser indirekter
gegenvorschlag so durchkommt wir jetzt
ist bin ich gar nicht unglücklich muss
ich sagen
gut das werden wir sehen das war ja wo
genau die ja ich bin nach wie vor ich
glaube nicht dass das wirklich was gut
ist aber da geht es auch um politische
vernunft es geht um kompromisse usw
ich muss noch mal sagen ich bin sehr
sehr froh können wir überhaupt über die
sind hier diskutieren mal es gibt
probleme das ist gar nicht zu bestreiten
und wir können jetzt wirklich auch über
die instrumente reden und da würde ich
dann eben wenn das ganze mit diesem
indirekten vorschlag durchkommt werden
ich eben auch diesen haften diese haften
das werden wir sie aufnehmen dieser
vorschlag dann ausfällt im parlament und
wie sie dann darauf reagieren ja wie
schaut denn dieser vorschlag und das
gesetz jetzt in frankreich das seit gut
einem jahr in kraft ist aus ich muss
ehrlich gestehen es ist ein sehr
komplexer französischer text ich bin
nicht sicher ob ich ihn verstanden habe
ich habe ihn mit einem wirtschaftsanwalt
angeschaut was klar ist es ist natürlich
eine es geht auch ohne sorgfaltspflicht
es geht soweit ich das verstanden haben
gibt es da auch eine haftungs
möglichkeit dass es gibt eine
klagemöglichkeit ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher wie die französischen gerichte
mit solchen taten umgehen aber eher das
leicht gehen wie die initiative die die
juristen würden sagen es gibt nicht
diese beweislastumkehr waterford ist wie
in diesem zusammenhang
es gibt eine gewisse er das rauchen
schon aber es sind sehr viel weniger
unternehmen davon betroffen und es gibt
glaube ich noch keine erfahrung damit
und das ist ja ganz neu und übrigens das
katholische hilfswerk frankreich unserer
schwester in frankreich hat sehr stark
den engagiert politisch das
durchzusetzen
das zeigt eben dass wir in ganz vielen
ländern jetzt diese rechts
weiterentwicklung haben weil die politik
erkannt hat das unternehmen sehr viel
macht sehr viel einfluss haben
sie haben den kongo erwähnt stellen sie
sich mal vor der kongo oder leben 80
millionen menschen der national des
national budget des kongos
genauso hoch werden zürich die stadt
zürich hat das gleiche budget der stadt
kongo die unternehmen die dort arbeiten
haben budgets die das noch mal weit
übersteigen das heißt wir haben ja auch
ein ein machtverhältnis eine eine neue
realität die die politik jetzt versucht
aufzugreifen und zu sagen okay hier kann
man nicht immer sagen dass der staat
alles unter kontrolle hat
die unternehmen haben auch eine
sorgfaltspflicht die müssen ins boden
geholt werden und das ist jetzt mit der
konzern verantwortung eine riesen chance
dass die schweiz nicht nur vor angeht
sondern auch mit dem progressiven
ländern die was verändern wollen
da wirklich was bewirkt vor ort bei den
menschen gut das war jetzt das plädoyer
dafür nochmal ganz kurze dagegen was
spricht ist dieser initiative der
richtige weg um gegen
menschenrechtsverletzungen unentschieden
im ausland vorzugehen
ich kenne ihre analyse das unternehmen
zum teil heute sehr groß sind dass sie
mächtiger sind als die länder in denen
sie operieren ich teile ihre
einschätzung dass und eine ebene
moralische verpflichtung haben
menschenrechte zu schützen entsprechende
maßnahmen zu treffen
ich halte diesen rechtlichen mechanismus
der haftungen also der möglichen klage
nicht die sorgfaltspflichten die klage
halte ich für mich geeignet dass herr
beizubringen was sie möchten nämlich den
schutz der betroffenen menschen ganz
herzlichen dank wir sehen wie es wir
werden sehen wie es weitergeht mit der
initiative und dem gegenvorschlag besten
dank für dieses gespräch
handys werden bauern ja diese woche
haben katholikinnen und katholiken
fronleichnam gefeiert jungsozialisten
und freidenker wollen feiertage werden
fronleichnam weihnachten ostern und
pfingsten abschaffen
dagegen regt sich widerstand christliche
feiertage ein auslaufmodell
darüber debattieren wir nächste woche
hier in der sternstunde religion
[Musik]